you
[Music]
hi my name is Raghu I'm the founder and
CEO of data coral the startup based out
of San Francisco where we offer 10 - in
data infrastructure as a service I'll
talk a little bit about the company but
most towards the end but mostly going to
talk about some of the questions that
we've been trying to answer based on
some of my own learnings as I've worked
in data abstraction for a while a little
bit about myself so I used to work at
Internet companies like Yahoo and
Facebook and specifically at Facebook
during its kind of explosive growth
years had to deal with a lot of the
problems around scaling infrastructure
how do you make sure that you actually
support hundreds of customers by
providing like a shared infrastructure
and along the way also solved some of
the problems that Facebook had around
trying to anonymize data trying to make
sure that people inside of Facebook
itself we could kind of cordon off
different kinds of data to different
people I'll talk a little bit more about
all of those in terms of this talk
itself there's kind of two stories as
such that I would like to talk about and
for each one of them just give you a
sense for what exactly happened this is
again over five years ago now so chances
are that a lot of things have changed at
least in that large company I guess
Facebook but then turns out a lot of
those learnings are still applicable
right now and I'll talk a little bit
more about that and there's a couple of
assumptions that I'm making when I talk
about how you might apply some of those
learnings here one is that everybody is
actually moving to the cloud I know
actually in the conference itself I
talked to a few people who are like yeah
there's no way we're going to move to
the cloud but for those maybe for those
sets of people maybe that's kind of a
harder thing to kind of how to build out
a bunch of stuff themselves and then the
second thing is that yes people are in
the cloud but then clouds don't offer
everything and they don't want to spend
a bunch of time building everything
themselves so they will look to vendors
to solve a bunch of their
their infrastructure needs then the
question becomes what should you expect
off of these vendors and what has been
happening right now and where do we
believe that the world is moving the
first story is mainly about providing a
shared service as we can scale fairly
dramatically at Facebook back in 2008 we
had a fairly small kind of nascent
Hadoop cluster it was about 50 terabytes
and over a period of about five years
Facebook itself grew fairly dramatically
grew about like 12x but then along the
way as you could imagine if there are
more people on the platform on on the
product being more engaged and then
inside of Facebook itself there were
more people trying to leverage data to
build better product or understand user
behavior better so data infrastructure
as such actually the load on it would
grow kind of orders of magnitude more
than that and around 2011 we got to a
point where we couldn't build a data
center big enough to hold all the data
we kept moving to bigger and bigger
clusters but then after a point we were
like yeah there's no bigger cluster that
we could actually build up so as part of
the project that actually carved out
parts of this giant cluster and moved
compute storage and the data all into
like different data centers while kind
of providing I mean I wouldn't call it
24/7 operations but there was very very
little downtime as we did all of that
and the key part about kind of the
clouds that you see kind of here is that
we ended up having to build a
multi-tenant model right so we had like
one giant cluster everybody was kind of
pounding it but then we realized that
that was just not really scalable and
when you think about what it means to be
multi tenant you might have a bunch of
clusters like a handful of clusters
sitting in different data centers so
when we thought about tenants these were
different teams inside of Facebook
right so you'd have the arts team the
new street team photos team the growth
team and so on and our goal became to
make each of these teams become tenants
for our shared service but then when you
think about what market and it means
you're assigning tenants to these
clusters right and as these tenants grow
and shrink or mostly just grow a lot
you're having to do this solve this bin
packing problem so you have a bunch of
bins that are of specific sizes
depending on what cluster like how big
it is or how big it can grow and then
you know that there are these kinds of
customer these tenants that are also
growing and then you try to assign them
and as they start growing you how to
move them around so when you think about
like completely outside of Facebook
itself like when you think about SAS
products that are providing multi tenant
solutions you realize that they're
probably solving the same problem so
they're a shared service they have
hundreds of customers or like many
customers and they want to be able to
provide that as a multi multi tenant
service so what that means is that
they're constantly in their engineering
is spending time trying to move
customers between clusters or like
trying to grow clusters and so on so the
learnings while actually doing all of
this is a cluster management is actually
fairly hard especially I mean you saw
the previous talk is about just air flow
but then if you're it's not just air
flow but there might be databases that
you're working with or like queuing
systems or whatever else and each of
them are their own sets of clusters and
when you think about one overall set up
you realize that each of these clusters
are kind of interacting with each other
and as the amount of load increases on
this particular set up you start
realizing that SKUs start causing these
clusters to get into pretty bad States
and once something gets into a pretty
bad state you have to take the time to
actually fix it and then by then there's
a huge workload that is piled up and
then you have to go
do the backfill or whatever else that is
needed and this whole notion of shared
infrastructure is dead by a thousand
cuts
it's basically a point where if you have
one cluster that you're trying to
provide as a service for multiple
customers and they I mean they don't
know about each other right so they just
use it the way that they want to but
then if as a service provider you're not
able to actually handle the SKUs that
might happen or the bursts of activity
that might happen then your cluster is
always in this kind of state of
disrepair and you're always having to
fix it especially if you're growing
dramatically and the last point is
multi-tenancy itself has a bunch of
security implications right so if you
have data from multiple customers going
into the same set of clusters you know
that that data is kind of getting
commingled and for a bunch of data it's
kind of okay but for companies that are
trying to use these kinds of services if
this if they really care about the data
privacy they don't really like the fact
that their data is getting commingled
with some other company's data now the
question is what exactly can you do
right now as kind of customers are
trying to use these kinds of vendors
especially if you're in the cloud what
are the kinds of things that you would
want to expect from vendors to can
provide the question basically is is
multi-tenancy the right and a model the
question around this multi-tenancy
if you think about how SAS product or
software as a service itself was built
out the whole notion was of economies of
scale there'd be one company that will
provide one piece of functionality but
across multiple customers but that means
that the underlying infrastructure would
be shared and hence it would be cheaper
faster to set up and so on but then when
you think about what's happening around
serverless computing
you realize that a lot of the shared
infrastructure spend or like the
economies of scale that you might get by
sharing infrastructure maybe you don't
need that sharing of infrastructure
anymore and once you start kind of
pulling the thread on what service
computing is actually able to do for you
maybe you can get to a point where you
can have multiple isolated installations
where it's kind of fully secure and of
course the good news about service
computing is that there's absolutely no
cluster management needed you don't need
to get into a point where these clusters
get into bad states and so on I can go
into more detail about kind of what it
means for a service to be service for
the customer versus it being service for
the vendor as well the key difference
that you might realize is just because
it's service for the customer does not
mean that it's actually service for the
customer service for the customer does
not mean that it's also service for the
vendor so the vendors themselves are
doing cluster management and like trying
to keep warm nodes and all of that stuff
but then they provide the the interface
for the customer that it's actually
service but the key thing that happens
with something like this is that the
vendors themselves are spending a
significant amount of engineering to try
to make the service be as seamless as
possible and more often than not they
end up passing that cost aren't the
customer so that's kind of the overall
part then the question is okay now let's
say you are working with these vendors
if security is really important for you
what are the kinds of questions that you
can ask these vendors can you ask them
again if you are in the cloud for them
to actually be able to run their
software inside of your VPC inside of
your network so that no data actually
leaves your systems you'd use things
like VPC peering are people familiar
with what VPC peering is okay so this is
basically a way where you allow for
traffic
it like data to be moved from one system
to another we thought actually going
over the internet so this is basically a
pretty strong security feature that you
would want to expect especially if you
don't want your data to kind of keep
flying around around the Internet and if
your vendors are able to actually
provide something like that then that
means that you're in luck pretty good
place as far as your own data security
is concerned and in terms of what you
can do as you use these kinds of vendors
is and especially if these vendors
provide for your managed services they'd
want some privileges in your cloud to be
able to actually run that software in
those situations it'll be good if you
can actually just cordon off that vendor
into its own kind of cloud account so
that it doesn't interact with everything
else that you are kind of running and
you apply this notion of principle of
least least privilege so that you only
offer the roles to these vendors that
are absolutely needed to run their
software and as a as a customer or as
the owner of the cloud account you can
enable all the auditing that will allow
you to kind of see exactly what's going
on in that particular installation that
your vendor destroyed so it turns out
there are actually a few companies that
do some parts of it right where storage
is actually like if you're on AWS they
expect storage of your data to be in
your s3 and then they can spin up
compute inside of your AWS account if
that's basically what you want but not
all of them are doing that and our hope
or like our belief is that as people
want to kind of take care of their own
data and make sure that they have full
control over who gets to see that data
they'll start trying to push vendors to
provide services that can actually run
inside of their own
that make sense yeah so I'll just move
on to the next part of this which is
around data privacy itself and just kind
of introduce around GDP are one of the
biggest challenges around GDP are
especially for analytic systems is this
notion of the right to be forgotten so
turns out we had actually worked on this
problem of right to be forgotten way
before there was GDP are because they
were kind of rumblings even back in like
2011 or so around this so when you think
about what does this actual problem mean
it basically says when a user comes like
they're using your product over maybe a
few years let's say and then one fine
day they come in and say you know what
forget about me so now imagine all the
data that you may have kind of collected
as they have used the product like
legitimately collected all of that
information and then all of this
information was actually stored inside
of your analytics databases because you
want to do longitudinal analysis or
anything like that and again because if
you are using big data systems they are
typically based off of file based
storage like HDFS or s3 or whatever else
then you get into this problem of a user
coming and saying okay now forget about
me you are essentially goes look through
every single piece of data that they may
have generated and the derived data that
may include something that will tie the
derived data back to them right so if
you think about true compliance as a
company this is basically what you would
have to do which is not just kind of
delete the raw data if a user says
forget about me but all the analysis
that you might have done and kind of
kept around because you want to kind of
save even maybe some aggregated
information or you're trying to capture
rate profiles over a period of time or
whatever else
and just kind of thinking about this
type of problem kind of makes her head
hurt right so how exactly are you going
to keep track of are essentially index
at a user level all the data that may
have been kind of stored in this
analytics database not just a source
data but a bunch of derived data as well
so clearly at Facebook we did have to
take on the problem we did what we call
proactive anonymization so this notion
of anonymization is kind of it's a an
attempt at trying to be compliant while
still not losing the optionality of data
so very simple kind of example is let's
say a hundred people use your product
last year 100 unique people and today
five of those users came and said forget
about me so now tomorrow if you ask the
question how many users use my product
last year are you gonna return the
answer ninety-five or is it going to be
hundred because you had to go delete
that data and having pretty simple stuff
right then you start thinking about okay
it's not just about unique counts there
may be other things that are they don't
really tie the information back to the
user but still or it may tie the
information back to the user but if they
say that you need to forget about them
you need a very efficient way of cutting
the the connection right and that's a
challenge that we took on the very first
thing that we did was of course this was
like a high warehouse so there's a bunch
of like hundreds of thousands of tables
and and partition millions of partitions
and so on and for each of these tables
we
we semi-automatically came up with this
notion of semantic types so there would
be like an IP address type it could be
name different things in different
tables because well it's data
democratization right like different
people call things differently but then
we needed the semantic types to be
standardized and for each of these
semantic types we had defined an anima
is a ssin functions that would take
something like an IP address but then
return back
a masked IP and that's specific to that
semantic type irrespective of which
table it had a column with that
semantics type and there were some that
word I mean you just could not keep any
piece of information we just kind of
null it out like a full name let's say
and the user ID type though was a pretty
unique type for us so we actually I the
the thing about Facebook specifically is
that the user ID the number used to be a
publicly available ID it was in the URLs
and things like that and that same user
ID he was also in a bunch of data that
was captured about that user the
activity whatever else that their done
so for this specific case we came up
with a replacement ID for this user ID
which was randomly generated so the idea
was for a given user ID if that user ID
was in a mapping table then in that
mapping table there would be a
replacement ID for that user ID without
that entry of user ID replacement idea
in a mapping table there is no way to
tie the user ID on the replacement ID so
you might get sense of where we are
going here the idea was instead of
trying to go and null out user IDs which
would essentially kind of eliminate or
get your analysis like historical
analysis to become incorrect we wanted
to replace these user IDs with randomly
generated you
we mapped replacement IDs where the
mapping itself was actually centralized
in one place that could just be worked
on or that could be updated whenever a
user said forget about me so this goes
into a little bit more detail about kind
of how this whole thing worked so this
there was a huge kind of column or data
column level tagging that happened
between the column names and semantic
types in different tables and there's a
bunch of tables that were identified as
having PII or personally identifiable
information and this is all hive so you
can think of each of these little boxes
there as high table partitions and let's
say there was these were all kind of
daily table partitions and the final
kind of table there or the final
partition there is for the current day
so one of the things about right to be
forgotten was you had let's say 30 or 90
days to actually scrub your all of your
systems off of that user data once a
request was submitted so that we treated
as kind of the retention line and then
remember there was this mapping from
like types semantic types to the
anonymized values we take every single
partition of these tables with PII and
we create an anonymized partition for
that same table which was so if let's
say this was a 30-day retention that you
need it or 30-day kind of window that
you had we'd start doing this on Animas
ation like 27 days for 27 day old data
so that way you're not as I let you're
just not duplicating a bunch of data so
the table in the middle is anonymized
version where all the types the IP
addresses have been masked the user IDs
have been replaced by these replacement
IDs and names have been nulled out or
whatever else and remember that this is
only done once so you're anonymous a
particular partition only
and once you write it it's done
irrespective of how many users say
forget about me you're not touching that
partition again and then there is this
replacement ID table which is this
mapping table which essentially just
corresponds to the users that showed up
that day or all the users that were
deemed active on that day right so the
way to think about it is for you to be
able to retrieve that most of the kind
of the full data you can join the
anonymize table back to the replacement
idea table to get a reasonable version
of the data without everything kind of
null doubt so what this did is it
allowed us to keep data for much longer
the anonymous data could be kept pretty
much forever while still being able to
kind of be compliant and of course
because of these replacement IDs which
are unique a lot of the like those
replacement IDs were stable as in for a
given user ID there only be one
replacement ID across all of time right
once you say once they'd say ok forget
about me you just remove that mapping
and then that's it there's no way you
can tie that back so this is basically
it took us a while as you can imagine we
had like tens of megabytes of data to
anonymize this way but there's a lot of
these kinds of learnings where we
realized that by just operating at the
so a lot of this mapping and all of that
stuff was done by our data scientists
they were the ones who knew the
semantics of the data or the that
different types of columns that were
there and what the mappings were and as
the data infrastructure team we ended up
providing all the infrastructure that
was needed and the scaffolding so that
this kind of automation are
automatically proactively anonymizing
data that entire flow was handled by us
so the question is what would we do if
we had to kind of start all over again
right
the biggest challenge definitely was the
fact that we had to separate out PII and
non PII data after the fact that just
just dealing with history and anybody
who has dealt with data enough kind of
knows that if there is a bug in an
application you just go fix the
application you push it out a new
version you're done with data processing
you're going back and fixing history and
that dramatically increases the
complexity of what kind of problem you
you're the kinds of problems that you're
solving so this the second thing is that
by actually taking on this task of
defining these semantic types what we
realized is that it gave us a bunch of
discipline around saying okay what is
the actual data that's act that is being
kind of captured or like stored in the
analytics systems and we end up ended up
doing being a lot more conservative in
terms of saying if a table was not
tagged as either having PII or not you
just have like a 30-day retention so
that you don't even have to worry about
it we'll just get a deleted so people
who cared about their data had to kind
of come up with the right tagging and
make sure that they could keep the data
around and when you think about what
product or anonymous a shinned us in
some sense you are unnecessarily
deleting a bunch of data right so a user
might have not come and told you forget
about me but your anonymizing their data
anyway but that seemed to be like a
reasonable compromise while for the
scales that we had to stay compliant
while still keeping that optionality of
data as data scientists call it so now
now that we are in this kind of post GDP
our world the question is what can you
do so that you can again stay compliant
while still save a bunch of your data
the first thing is to try and use tools
that make it fairly straightforward for
you to actually specify the semantic
types there are some bi tools that we
have used in the past meta ways being
one where you can actually tag columns
and tables with kind of some
descriptions and but then you need to
have your own conventions to specify the
the semantic types and the second thing
that you'd need is a way to kind of
separate your PII data from other usage
data as close to the source as possible
so don't let a bunch of derived tables
end up having PII information unless you
absolutely need it that level of
discipline will kind of save you from
having to go back and anonymize the data
or going forward but then it's actually
pretty hard to do it at source so if
you're pulling data from like Salesforce
or senders many of these kind of
applications turns out there is going to
be PII information there and you do have
to join that with like a bunch of other
data so in those cases you will have to
kind of take on this load of trying to
actually do the process of anonymization
so we had dealt with hive at Facebook
where this was a file system based
storage so table updates were not very
efficient but nowadays there are
databases I mean redshift being one
snowflake being another where you can
actually do row level kind of updates
they'll eventually kind of vacuum the
table or whatever and you can like it do
not use up too much space but if you
don't use those kinds of tables and
again like the the suggestion here is to
not go and delete records but actually
replace them with anonymize versions of
them so that you can kind of keep at
least like a skeleton of that data
around even though the user said forget
about us
and in terms of the data privacy itself
inside of your company as in if you want
to kind of cordon off sensitive data to
only certain teams and leave all the
other data sets to be available for
other other parts of the company
I mean databases do provide role level
and column level security but then they
it seems like they're way too fine
grained so it would be incredibly hard
for you to kind of manage its like
managing Network ACLs or whatever right
you you need to know the implications of
all of these rules and how they interact
with each other so there's one
complication around kind of role bit not
always but data dependency based privacy
and I'll get to that but other than that
if you can organize your again sensitive
data and non kind of PII kind of data
you can level schema schema level access
controls and make it a lot more kind of
easy to manage the key thing about I
told you about data dependency based
privacy is that databases themselves
don't really do that good of a job you
typically need an application on top so
the way to kind of think about this
problem is let's say you have a customer
success person inside of your company
you only want to allow them to do
analytics on accounts that they own
right not all accounts now you can
technically build a schema per customer
success person but that just seems way
to kind of complicate it
instead whatever analytics you end up
kind of computing you would store it in
a schema that all customer success
people are able to access but then maybe
at the application layer you
automatically add filters so that they
only get to see the data that they have
a onto objects for which they have a
relationship with so again like these
are kind of I feel like I'm gave you
like up
a pretty complicated problem that we
ended up solving at Facebook and then
I'm kind of giving you ideas about how
you might be able to deal with not as
massive data sets but still fairly
strong kind of compliance requirements
that you guys have hopefully that was
useful I'm again going to kind of switch
over and talk about kind of how we have
been applying these kinds of learnings
and others in the company that we've
been building we launched the company
yesterday actually so kind of pretty
exciting day for us the overall thing
that we do a data coral is that we
provide as secure and end-to-end data
infrastructure as a service inside of
our customers cloud so it's basically
it's your data it could be sitting
anywhere it is your AWS account
it's your V PC and we provide these
services building blocks that are
implemented predominantly using a SS
lambda I'm guessing people are familiar
lambda and we have kind of just pull the
thread on what parts of date and
end-to-end data infrastructure stack can
be represented as lambda functions so we
call like we call them functional
building blocks or data functions
basically and there are three kinds of
functionality that we believe data
infrastructure typically cannot provide
one is collecting data it could be
pulling data or like receiving data from
a bunch of places so we have building
blocks for that and once you receive
that data you want to be able to get the
data into a database that you can
actually then use to transform that data
so we support different query engines
we support redshift Athena hives part
things like that and within these
databases and depending on how much time
I have yeah I can get into a little bit
more around what happens in the organize
side but at a very high level we kind of
let you just declare that you need data
from different sources and then make all
of the data available in
an analytics engine and inside of that
analytics engine you can define views
and views on top of other views not
really build out jobs and tasks but just
declare views in the language that's
native to that query engine and then you
can declare that the final view result
not just be used in I mean you can query
it of course in lack of the eye tool or
something but you can also publish the
data back into applications so instead
of kind of showing a tabular dashboard
to your sales person you're making that
exact same information show up in their
own Salesforce so that way they're not
having to move between systems so these
are the building blocks that we have
kind of built out and what ends up
happening is because of this declarative
interface that you have come up with
you can specify an end-to-end flow and
once you specify it the underlying
implementation which is like a bunch of
building blocks that are all serval as
they all get deployed inside of your V
PC and you end up getting an end-to-end
data infrastructure and we provide kind
of 24/7 operations so that you don't
really have to worry about how the data
is flowing whether the data is fresh
whether the whether there's any problems
with changes and schemas and things like
that and what ends up happening with
this is that security is actually built
in so no data is leaving your systems
it's in fact all encrypted using your
keys so what that means is that even
though we provide a fully managed
service we don't get to see your data
and we can not just because we have gone
through compliances in fact we have gone
through maybe a few security audits but
no real compliance but we can actually
prove to you that we don't see get to
see your data and not because we have
some processes in place and that is what
we believe
kind of most vendors should be doing as
well
I'm just gonna show one other slide and
yeah and this is the kind of the data
centric interface that I was talking
about where you can just declare views
and inside of the database right so any
database that you choose and then we
look into the system catalog of the
database and given that we know where
data is coming from how it is getting
organized through these view definitions
and where it is going we compute just
like how databases compute query plans
we compute a data flow plan right and
you get full visibility into how the
data is flowing how fresh it is we have
a micro batch kind of way of doing the
processing so you get to see full
visibility into kind of the data
provenance it's all because as people
who are building these transformations
you know exactly what data a particular
transformation depends on in fact you
coded code that up but then you code
them up into these jobs and tasks that
then kind of obscure those kinds of data
dependencies and you're having to go
through a lot more additional work to
get those get back the data provenance
information that the person who actually
defined these transformations already
knew about all right so our goal has
been to make data be front and center
not kind of jobs and tasks and then
provide kind of full visibility into
kind of how you can debug data problems
like for example if there are schema
changes that you're you're making an
update to a view we know that there's a
bunch of subsequent views or even like a
published step that might get affected
we are able to kind of detect that and
kind of tell you okay you need to
actually change these other things as
well and we end up creating this notion
of update sets where there's a one
consistent update to this entire graph
right so we are not relying on the
runtime to fail to make that to make
those changes so you can learn more at
our at our website
I know how to do this and yeah with that
I'll and thank you thank you for the
talk so as you probably know GD part GD
P R is affected the media marketing and
AD tech industry the most have you
looked into security and anonymizing PII
data through Google's at data hub
platform no not specifically to the
platform but maybe you and I can chat
offline to see if there are specific
things that might help
[Music]